for the second year in a row on the
forbes list of the world's billionaires
the planet's richest woman is l'oreal
heiress francois bettencourt myers of
france worth an estimated 74.8 billion
dollars bettencourt myers is an
estimated 1.2 billion dollars richer
than a year ago making her the 14th
richest person in the world the 68 year
old french citizen is the vice chair of
the board of l'oreal the world's largest
cosmetics and beauty company which her
chemist grandfather founded in 1909
bettencourt myers and her family own
about 33 percent of l'oreal stock she's
been a member of the company's board
since 1997 and her two sons john victor
meyers and nicholas meyers also sit on
the board
bettencourt myers first landed on the
forbes billionaires list in 2018 after
her mother lilianne bettencourt then the
planet's richest woman died in 2017 at
the age of 94. in 2007 bettencourt myers
famously sued close family friend
francois marie banier for allegedly
siphoning more than one billion dollars
worth of gifts from lillian bonier was
later sentenced to three years in jail
and was ordered to reportedly pay back
16.5 million dollars to bettencourt and
her family as the world's largest beauty
manufacturer l'oreal owns more than 35
cosmetic skin care and personal care
brands its lead portfolio companies
include maybelline garnier and nyx
far from astonishing conglomerate the
100 year old company has continued to
stay fresh-faced via technology and
acquisitions it recently launched a
headset to help people make precise
fragrance choices but more important
than its tech incubator l'oreal
continues to acquire indie brands and
form strategic alliances to stay on top
of trends all in all l'oreal's group of
companies generated more than 35 billion
dollars in revenue in 2021 and the
company employs 85 000 people worldwide
bettencourt myers is also president of
her family's philanthropic foundation
which champions france's role in the
advancement of the sciences and arts